elon musk's girlfriend grimes shares
topless video of her alien back tattoo
and details very elaborate design
process kai if you want to pull that up
a business insider
so adam brought up the story says i
swear to god if we don't cover this on
the podcast i'm going to lose my mind
okay
so the musician 33 real name claire
elise boucher
unveiled her beautiful alien scars
tattoo which covered her entire back it
is little
wonder grimes was given a nod to
extraterrestrial activity given her
recent voicing
of plans to relocate to mars after she
turns 50 to help erect the human colony
and her partner
the world's richest man revealed an
ambitious plan to get humans on mars by
seven years before nasa aims to land
astronauts on the red planet so
what do you think about that like what
reaction did you have today so here's my
reaction and
zero percent of my action actually has
to do with grimes herself
because if she wasn't dating or the baby
mama of elon musk it would just be a
weirdo chick that does stuff like this
so
kudos to her if she wants to get tatted
up like an alien and be also
into anime and all that stuff good for
her but what this does is gives us
some deep insight into how elon musk
thinks
and what he's doing in the bedroom and
what's going on in his mind and
basically
here's my opinion on uh our friend elon
musk
the guy's worth a hundred and something
billion dollars
200 billion okay so the guy's killing
he's on top of the world arguably
him and bezos the top two entrepreneurs
on the planet
he's had some gorgeous women in his in
his life he used to date
amanda heard who was um johnny depp
johnny depp's ex so he's had women he's
had fun he's had money
this is why he's so obsessed with space
and spacex
and everything that he's doing with that
because he's done everything on earth
and all he's about
at this point is having sex with aliens
and he's
turning his girl into a freaking alien
and they had their son the kid has an
alien name that's a
x e g b d whatever the hell it is elon
musk i'm coming out and saying it i have
alt
amazing respect for you elon musk
[ __ ] aliens i said it there it is he
he's doing it he wants to do it he wants
to travel to space
he's had so much success in his life
he's so at this point that all he can
focus on
is otherworldly things like banging
aliens
there it is
[Music]
and i'm out did you eat some burritos
this morning show some pictures of them
together let's get it let's
say hang on here get on the ball here
stay here kai stay here
this whole story is bs because senabet
david drew that to me and
handed me that piece of paper the last
time i was in town so meaning it doesn't
even look like a tattoo no
it's satisfactory and the real question
is how'd they get it i'm more worried
about
email security on your server because
your daughter drew that and you gave it
to me she was sorry
other pictures other pictures
no i'm i'm doubling down that elon musk
is looking to get the space to bang more
aliens
there i said i don't know but there's
there's just no
okay she's normal in that i mean there's
nothing to it i mean it didn't look like
him
see more pictures pull that one up big
screen on the top right
this guy can have any woman in the world
and he wants to bang an alien
this is what i'm saying you're so funny
could elon musk not arguably not have
any women in the world
let me not have anyone in my heart can
he have any woman in the world meaning
good looking guy working
dollars sure he can do whatever he wants
yeah so why is he
why is he you know with an alien so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you